how much can we really know about the
universe beyond our galaxy the Hubble
telescope has enabled us to see objects
in space as far as 13 billion light
years away but this still doesn't give
us the answers to all our questions
questions like what is the universe made
of which elements are the most abundant
does space contain undiscovered forms of
matter could there be
antimatter stars or galaxies some of
these questions cannot be answered
solely from visual images but what if we
had messengers bringing us physical data
from distant parts of the cosmos beyond
the reach of explorers or satellites in
a way we do and these space messengers
are called cosmic rays cosmic rays were
first discovered in 1912 by Victor Hess
when he set out to explore variations in
the atmospheres level of radiation which
had been thought to emanate from the
Earth's crust by taking measurements
onboard a flying balloon during an
eclipse has demonstrated both that the
radiation actually increased at greater
altitudes and that the Sun could not be
its source the startling conclusion was
that it wasn't coming from anywhere
within the Earth's atmosphere but from
outer space our universe is composed of
many astronomical objects billions of
stars of all sizes black holes active
galactic nuclei asteroids planets and
more during violent disturbances such as
a large star exploding into a supernova
billions of particles are emitted into
space although they are called rays
cosmic rays consist of these high-energy
particles rather than the photons that
make up light rays while the light from
an explosion travels in a straight line
at its famous constant speed the
particles are trapped in extraordinary
loops by magnetic shock waves generated
by the explosion crossing back and forth
through these magnetic field lines
accelerates them to almost the speed of
light before they escape
there are lots of cosmic rays in space
and some of these particles have
traveled for billions of years before
reaching earth when they enter our
atmosphere they collide with the
molecules they're generating secondary
cosmic rays lighter particles with less
energy than the original most of these
are absorbed into the atmosphere but
some are able to reach the ground even
passing through our bodies at sea level
this radiation is fairly low but people
who spend a lot of time at higher
altitudes such as airline crews are
exposed to much more
what makes cosmic rays useful as
messengers is that they carry the traces
of their origins by studying the
frequency with which different particles
occur scientists are able to determine
the relative abundance of elements such
as hydrogen and helium within the
universe but cosmic rays may provide
even more fascinating information about
the fabric of the universe itself
an experiment called the Alpha Magnetic
Spectrometer AMS has recently been
installed onboard the International
Space Station containing several
detectors that can separately measure a
cosmic ray particles velocity trajectory
radiation mass and energy as well as
whether the particle is matter or
antimatter while the two are normally
indistinguishable their opposite charges
enable them to be detected with the help
of a magnet
the Alpha Magnetic Spectrometer is
currently measuring 50 million particles
per day with information about each
particle being sent in real time from
the space station to the AMS control
room at CERN over the upcoming months
and years is expected to yield both
amazing and useful information about
antimatter the possible existence of
dark matter and even possible ways to
mitigate the effects of cosmic radiation
on space travel as we stay tuned for new
discoveries look to the sky on a clear
night and you may see the International
Space Station where the Alpha Magnetic
Spectrometer
receives the tiny messengers that carry
cosmic secrets